so from the border now customs and
border protection officials ordering
supervisors to push employees for their
compliance with the administration's
coveted vaccine mandate or they could be
fired themselves former acting ice
director tom homan with us now fox news
contributor tom good morning to you you
know the issue well
our numbers suggest that about half of
the border agents
the status of their vaccination is not
known and
you know who who knows
where that gives what do you think their
concern is today tom on the mandate
look this isn't really a vaccination
issue it's the abortion relations are
protesting mandate by leadership they
fill out these forms where these agents
think that their medical information
between them and their doctor so they
know they trust these guys wear a gun
they trust these guys to take a life if
the situation warrants it they don't
trust them they answer questions
truthfully you know i just got the flow
chart bill i want to chose you quick
this is a flowchart that was given out
to leadership of border patrol and right
here in the middle if you fail to get
vaccinated you don't win the permit
re-education phase
education phase it's like this is china
they're going to be re-educated to
follow these explicit rules of the
government or they're going to lose
their jobs this is going to be
devastating to border security because a
lot of agents will lose their jobs over
this mandate
which means then tom let me just let me
just slow you down a little bit if they
lose their job you think the border
situation is bad now what happens then
well this administration doesn't care
about the border situation right they
haven't done one thing to slow the flow
there's been no enforcement strategy no
no consequence deterrence to these
people entering legally it's all about
welcoming bringing these people and
releasing them so they can care if the
border choice is half what it used to be
because this just means more people get
in the united states but what the board
of children is really angry about i've
talked to hundreds of them i talked to
one yesterday saying i'm mandated fill
this form out or go get re-educated in
the meantime i was on detail in real
grand valley i released myself hundreds
of people uh migrants who were
positively coveted they were tested they
were positive and i was told to release
them so is this really about covid is it
really about protecting american people
and jen sake stands at the white house
says well we don't test them they're not
here that long well look she obviously
doesn't know the issues because these
people aren't going nowhere in the in
the follow-up question jenna saki should
have been well how long does it take to
affect somebody and the same board of
trading told me not only releasing
positive covert people every down down
there we're releasing criminals serious
criminals if they have coveted they
don't want to detain them
he was there when they processed an
illegal immigrant for he had coveted he
had a conviction of murder and there are
total releases they don't want to detain
coveted people even though ice has
facilities they have negative pressure
rooms they can put copied positive
people there keep them isolated
different air flow not the rest of the
facility and keep an isolate to get
beyond this infection period but the
administration don't want to detain
people now you make it very important
yeah i get it we'll see how it comes out
now speaking of ice quickly now northern
california san mateo county joins a
number of other bay county bay area
counties where the sheriff says we're
not going to cooperate with ice if they
asked us to turn someone over to them
here's the statements become apparent to
me that complying with those requests
regarding the pending release of
undocumented individuals who have
committed serious crimes is undermining
the trust we need to protect the
community it simply is not worth losing
the trust of many members of the public
by continuing to process these requests
from ice what's your read on that
because i saw where you said that
sheriff's misinformed how so
yeah it's apparent he doesn't know he's
talking about release knowingly release
some public safety threats back into the
public is going to commit more it's
going to create more crime and when you
release an illegal alien criminal where
is he going to recommit crime in the
very community in which he lives the
immigrant community so by doing what
he's doing he's putting the immigrant
community at greater risk of crime and
the victim and witnesses who they say
they're trying to protect do they want
the criminal back in their neighborhood
to take revenge on the victim and
witness no this sheriff's misinformed he
you know sit down and talk to me for
five minutes i'll explain to you why
this doesn't matter i'm sure you will
releasing public safety threats into the
public is ridiculous yeah tom thanks tom
holman san mateo county that is again
northern california we'll see what
happens as an effect of that decision
thank you tom nice to see you hi
everyone i'm brian kilmeade i want you
to do me a favor i want you to click to
subscribe to the fox news youtube page
this is the only way that i know for
sure that you're not going to miss any
great commentary any great news bites
any great interviews coming your way on
fox you can get it all here on youtube
so subscribe right now